i eq you care about the show this is my
carrying face yes yeah christian's
looking up to this guy you look like uh
i want to um
like wander lusty yeah hmm like if i
could um do a sound to it for the
audience it's you going hmm you
christian has his hand on his knuckle
and he's a glaring face yeah it's
wonderlusty he's dreamily looking off
into the distance uh why are we talking
about i'm not sure oh okay you're right
well you know i was because it what it
did it reminded me of all those games as
kids that yeah that's right and so then
i went down this um
can you go down can you can you do have
your own rabbit hole can you like uh
facilitate your own rabbit hole i went
down a rabbit hole of i don't know
that's a good question i think i think
so why not why not i mean a rabbit hole
is not a real thing
well it is no i know but it's not you
it's it's a it's a warren it's it's
figurative
remember watership down how good that
was being
sad
it was about society and people getting
i was uh i'd like to read that again
yeah anyway
back to uh childhood games you know what
that so we were talking about some of
the ones that we used to play all the
time and
one that gave me anxiety well
operation was uh that was i think the
most anxiety inducing because it was it
was the sound that it made if you got it
wrong if you like touched the corners
you know you had to because just because
the sound was so like great is that when
you knew you would never be a surgeon
yeah
probably
i mean i wonder if surgeons played a lot
of operations kids and i wanted the venn
diagram
of
kids who played operations and we're
good at it and like good at it and and
people who ended up becoming surgeons
what other games did you place oh man
well so it sounds so that sound i was
thinking about this
how like awful it was to hear that sound
it was really like it was a
and simon says had that a little bit for
me the ding ding remember you'd have to
like
you know who's good at that was damien i
think
it was so smart yeah our older brother
um and if you got it wrong it was really
there's something about hearing that and
i think that had a blam
i forget that noise if you get it wrong
but i just remember like
getting so stressed out about the colors
and the sounds together
especially when it went on for a long
time and you're doing well
it gave me a bad association with the
name simon that's true simon says it's
like ugh why is simon saying these
annoying things i know it's like don't
tell me what to do simon has your
association with the name simon changed
at all over the years
since you played that game it really has
and i'll tell you how it first it was
the wonderful mike myers mike not mike
myers the halloween villain that's
michael michael myers mike michael myers
oh that's right that's michael myers
right yeah mike myers yeah mike myers is
the funny one the canadian yeah who
doesn't kill people mike myers is
funnier than michael myers
i think i think that you don't know you
don't know i mean michael myers might
have had a great sense of humor he just
when he wasn't killing people yeah
before he like went off the rails um
speaking of going off the rails uh
you're listening to life is short
uh simon why are we talking about well
so so mike mike myers did that simon
well hello my name is simon great sketch
on snl and i love that simon always had
after that had an innocent kind of like
light uh connotation to me and mike
myers really did a lot to change that
and then i fell in love with the work of
our guest today and that completely
altered it for good uh i now love
simon's and i'm so glad that we have one
on the show
he is he really is one of my favorites
um
we we had his partner his creative
partner on nick frost friend of the show
a couple months ago and maybe a year ago
well now we have the remainder of that
great british comedic duo the hilarious
i think brilliant simon pegg
i think he's brilliant i think so too
you don't bother to think simon pegg's
brilliant he's um and he's such a nice
guy i got to know him a little bit it's
one of those um
instagram relationships uh one of the
reasons i really enjoy instagram i got
to uh you didn't meet him through nick
frost uh i i did technically i mean
but but i got to
know him more we were texting about
it went down in the dms
yeah exactly i met him in passing with
nick um when i was in
nick had a little like sunday brunch
thing at his house in london nick loves
to cook and had a bunch of people over
and um simon was there but i didn't
really have occasion to talk to him
certainly as much as i wanted to um so
this was a great opportunity to
nerd out on one of my favorites um
he started doing
the show spaced if you haven't seen it
is um it's it's
legendary it's one of the great british
it's one of those shows that started the
the comedic british invasion of the late
90s early 2000s and um
and of course sean of the dead uh was
such a hit here and
hot fuzz all of his uh world's end i
love that all of his work with edgar
wright and um then he started doing
these huge blockbusters he was in star
trek series and uh and now mission
impossible people know him everyone
knows him um
so why are we why are we still
introducing him should we talk more
about monopoly and simon says
it was annoying it was really annoying i
wonder if that's why like people i
wonder if they were they must have been
deliberate about that with the text
sound the text alarm when you because
you want now a positive association just
being facetious i don't think we should
still i know i know i haven't said that
but i just thought about that like ding
you know what yeah it's positive it's up
and and
one day they're gonna develop technology
where if you get a bad text or a text
from someone you don't like it'll be
like game paint yeah i bet that's a good
idea i wonder if they have that or you
know would be good actually so that your
brain
so that you're not so
stuck on your phone and behold into your
phone it'd be good to develop that now
or every time you got a text it was like
ah yeah
it was a negative thing that's not a bad
idea so it didn't like send this little
burst of serotonin through your brain it
was just like
spooky um can we hear from simon peck
please oh
um now i have that voice in my head
ah yes simon pegg oh i can't wait to
start we better start it now
um okay here it is the great the
legendary the king o nerds
simon pegg
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
ah yes hey everybody oh hey it's
japanese good to see you me too man we
had a chance to like
sneak uh some looks at your can at your
place you have great memorabilia i'm
seeing a space poster and the shawn of
the dead shirt uh iconic now but this is
where all my kind of self-indulgent
junkies yes this is this is kind of my
place where i work you seem to live on a
very like
moorish property is that safe to say it
is it's an old um the first brick was
was laid in 1655.
it was built for the sheriff of
hertfordshire's wife wow
and um the joint all the joinery is done
by all the banisters and stuff are done
by um
a guy that did
henry viii's place
oh my god for i oh that's
wild i want uh that's
crazy wow
there's a lot of henry eighth guy has
got to be one of the best he's probably
the most famous
murderer of women yes yeah that's yeah
but impeccable taste
uh
but you know royal so he got away with
it yeah like yeah like a lot of oil but
i've heard you talk about this place in
that it sounds like i i hate this term
but there's a we have a term here i
don't know if they use it in the uk
called man cave oh this is my man yeah
yeah simon yeah well this room this is
kind of
during the first lockdown when i
realized that i could essentially
like many of us
certainly when it came to writing at
least work from home
and um and i was sitting in the kitchen
kitchen a lot and it was fine it was
nice to be home but i realized i needed
somewhere i could not be in everyone's
way and also
feel like i was at work yeah at home
so i ha i built this i say i built it
some lovely men came and built it for me
um this structure which is kind of right
on the other side of the the grounds
that we live in and um and all the stuff
in here is all stuff from things that
i've written so it's kind of because
it's where i'm going to write so
it's space and
you know
all that gospel have you seen nick
lately uh friend of the show nick frost
yeah we i went round to his for uh for
dinner just after christmas because we
hadn't seen it for a long time just
because we've been working and locked
down and all those things have been
getting in the way so we carved out some
special family time and we um we all
went over to the frost towers ah he
cooked he's amazing
i didn't realize simon that you wrote
uh
some of the star trek movies you wrote
on
uh all of the yeah beyond i'm beyond
endo you know right star trek beyond was
it was it was kind of handed to us about
six months out from production they had
a screenplay
they decided not to move forward with it
and then um
jj abrams
said can you write the film quickly
and so me and
me and a guy called doug jung we sort of
banged it out and uh it was a good
experience from scratch i mean did you
have any did they give you any outline
any um we need to have this character
no there were a couple of kind of sets
that they wanted sort of um yeah just to
include like a space station and we were
given free reign pretty much but
when you write a screenplay that close
to production there are people banging
on the door asking you how many
spaceships are there in this scene and
yeah
the actual first part of it was
extremely stressful and um scary but
when we got into the into the production
it was much more
like you know every day we'd workshop
the lines with the cast and
it was really good fun i bet i i would
imagine it would also be hard to come up
with an original
story there have been so many iterations
of star trek i mean god how many
episodes and how do you cull through all
of them
knowing whether or not you've um you're
coming up with something original yeah
that's true actually it's um
and also we've got to try and make a
star trek movie better than galaxy quest
of course of course the best
vehicles ever made of course i love how
much you love that movie we've
selfishly i want to talk
all about that movie um what were your
inspirations as a kid i mean were there
was star trek one of them i i know
you've talked about your love of
spielberg
thankfully going into writing a star
trek film
i i came in with an a fairly broad
knowledge of it at least the original
series you know and what doug and i set
out to do with that movie anyways was to
anyway was to try and
create like an episode of the show you
know
the previous two movie that sort of like
tried other things and and we thought
let's make an episode of star trek where
they're out in space and they're they're
on an adventure and it's sort of
self-contained
and there are plenty of
nods in in that film to other episodes
and characters that you know for the
deep core yes for the hard star trek
fans
so they know we love them
i i love the nines
for the brandon the brandon wiggers yes
well it was 966 that was the first
episode ever um yeah i i don't know if i
we've talked about that um simon but
my first day on set i remember um
doing sort of an amalgamation of like
there was a little i feel i feel hoffman
was just such a huge inspiration at the
time and i had still is of course but um
he his character in boogie night
specifically you know how
did you say how oh how like eager he was
and like how
he was he was so um
single singularly focused on dirk
diggler you know he had this real
like i just want um and
and very serious as well very serious
you know yeah
and like self-conscious and like kind of
like pulling on his shirt and like
whatever you know and um there was that
and then the comic book guy i like i was
really into the this on the simpsons at
the time who was so there was something
kind of like um militant about his
fandom like yeah best episode ever you
know he was very
er emphasizing like the toxic fanboy
before the toxic fanboy was a thing yes
yes well
i remember the um
i sang to the director like is it too
much
is it too much am i doing a lot and he
said no no in fact you could go further
because um and he gave me a copy of
trekkies
uh that the documentary right yeah and
there's a character in that uh on whom
my character i think was directly based
uh whose name i think is also brandon
and i realized i had never seen anything
like i had never seen fandom
represented like that um
that passionate and um
you know in intense and so you must i
imagine
be the recipient of a lot of that was
obviously certainly a lot of the love
but also a lot of the vitriol i mean
they can get really
like aggressive they can get hostile
they know what they like yeah and you
know and often they like what they know
so it's to do different stuff right
you know i think that the the problem
that a lot of the the original star trek
fans had with the the movies the kelvin
timeline movies was that they became
a lot more about the kind of action and
spectacle because
that's kind of what brings people into
those kind of movies these days and of
course the original series was they were
like little one-hour plays yeah they
were very
low-fi
moral kind of pales and much more sort
of cerebral than the kind of whiz-bang
of of of the modern day sort of
blockbuster yeah but i think what we
tried to do with beyond was to was to
have our cake and eat it and have the
have all that stuff but also because
justin lynn the director the one thing
he did say is that i want to destroy the
enterprise oh and i was like and i was
like the fat i was like
like
i was like no way yeah
you know like it's been done it was done
in three and it was done in seven yeah
and i was kind of like
there was like a big fight we had a big
fight oh really all right why was that
why was that so important to him
well because and i get it now because
what he wanted to do was he wanted to
take away the the thing
that bonds the crew together you know
our hero yeah take away the physical
thing which keeps them together and and
then see if they they
it can exist without it you know see if
they can reunite
and and i
as a metaphor for their sort of
you know professional relationship
um
it worked because it was like you you
take that away and are they still
friends and of course they are that's
yeah
their team
so it was does it happen in search for
spark and now i'm
what's that does it does
so also okay so now you're gonna be the
one destroying it's gonna be your script
in which the enterprise enterprise yeah
i got all that [ __ ] from the
they must have known and kind of um
anointed you as uh they must have
accepted your pedigree i mean from just
from spaced alone and you you the
characters from
shauna shawn of the dead your characters
also seem to be
um
seem to have a real knowledge and a love
of uh movies like that star trek type
movies um
yeah i did i did one of the the big
conventions in vegas and it was a really
warm lovely event you know the fans are
there's there's a myth about fandom
which which sort of
edges towards that kind of petulant
entirely i know and there is that those
are the fringes i would say yeah yeah
but the general the general population
of the of the fan communities that just
love what they're into you know i
agree simon i've done a few of those
horror conventions and um i know i find
them to be really like
on the whole just lovely people and
there's something so
uh
heartwarming not to sound sentimental
about um
adults who are still holding on to
there's a real like child-like sense of
wonder still which which i'm i'm not i
love being close to that yeah it's kind
of heartwarming and you know that
someone who would probably
tear a strip off you online when they
actually meet you for real they're
actually like well you know what i'm
actually a big fan of yours right you
know it's funny i i know i once i there
was a thing on fair facebook or
something which i don't have but um
somebody a friend of mine pointed it out
it was like the i hate justin long fan
club and it was
it was runs and it was run by some guy
and there were members you know and so i
create
i don't do this stuff like this anymore
but i created a twitter a facebook
account or whatever to join just to join
so
so i was a member of the i
hate justin long fan club and that kind
of and i would say things like i agree
you know and i think that kind of blew
it up and i think then he realized i
don't know why but a couple years later
i was at a concert and somebody
approached me
kind of sheepishly uh as you'd expect
and he said he identified himself as the
founder of that the moderator the
moderator of that club and i i was
fascinated by him i i i was with a
seeing a friend's show and she was
backstage and i and i brought him i
introduced him to people oh this guy
hates me more than anyone but i and i
was just fascinated and the guy said um
to your point he was like well actually
not so much he was like not so much
anymore i i i thought dragged me to hell
was pretty he's pretty good or something
he said begrudgingly something about
dragging me to hell
that's got what kind of like yeah but um
i i said you know what but
bill hader tells a very similar story he
came across exactly the same thing on
some online chat room
i hate bill hayder and it was full of
people who had and then he he was
driving somewhere one day getting driven
and the driver was like uh hey guess
what
i run the uh no yeah i mean
he was like all pally like he wanted to
be friends like he was just some kind of
gang
he didn't realize how much it [ __ ]
hurts
online
no it's wild i don't look at that stuff
anymore i actually find instagram is
nice for that stuff if you do if
somebody is kind of spewing something
it's easy enough to to block them but um
instagram as well it just seems to be a
much more chilled community yeah it's
kind of you know it's photographs yeah
there's less there's less propaganda and
and you know
polemics on there yes it's just nice yes
yeah yeah i um and it's nice to connect
to fans to your point i mean they can be
really lovely and it's like um and as a
fan yourself i would imagine
uh now being the recipient of fan you
know adulation adoration must be i it
must be kind of surreal it must feel
like a very uh and knowing spielberg i
mean your life has really kind of become
every fan every
like movie nerds dream you're you're
working on these big
things it doesn't feel that way and
it does because i'm i'm as you said i i
i was a i'm a movie nerd you know i was
a kid i grew up loving that stuff and i
i think i try and
always maintain a connection to that
person in terms of you know if someone
comes up to say hello or whatever yeah i
always imagine how i if that was me
right do you know what i mean yeah i
kind of
suddenly think oh i'm now i've passed
into some other realm now right i'm
special now what does that happen yes
yes yeah i i heard i saw a commercial
for american idol the other day and um
they're playing it a lot uh katy perry
says to one of the contestants you're
and it's really dramatic you know and
she says
welcome to hollywood your life has just
begun
and i and my brother and i were like
your life has just begun what a wild way
to frame that you know
the suggestion being that well prior to
being in hollywood being like you know
celebrated yeah life is nothing that's
yes it was crazy
um what should have been your life has
just ended
your life as you know it will
unfortunately never be the same
what was your
tell me about little simon pegg
what was um
what was what were your ambitions when
you were a kid did you have do you ever
even think i mean i remember talking to
nick about
this and and he was just like not not at
all like it was not even on
his radar he was that he
the the condition in which he grew up
was
um was just never anything that was like
realistic were you were you
similar or did you did you have um
a dream to be where you are now
i guess i had a dream but i had no idea
that it was a possibility at all i mean
i kind of
you know i'd listen to john williams
scores in my grandmother's front room
and imagine myself in a star wars where
i was like luke's brother or something
yeah but
that was more actually projecting myself
into that universe rather than playing
luke's brother right
you know it was like writing the part of
luke's brother
yeah yeah
so um
so then i kind of i don't know i was at
school and
i was thinking of also what can i do i
lived in gloucestershire which is kind
of in the west of england it's on the
border with wales and it's far it's far
enough from london to feel like tatooine
you know
so i
i just had
no sort of illusions that i would be i
would be given access to any of this and
then i
i sort of went off to a college to do
a drama sort of course which
then got me into bristol university and
then and obviously you sort of inch
closer right to the world
that seems so far away and then um
and then yeah it all just sort of
happened and it was really funny i i
wound up working at l street studios
on the world's end i think it was and we
were shooting on the same sound stage
that um
yoda's house was from the empire striker
oh my god yes
and i i just thought geez this was that
was in l street do you know what i mean
oh i know how crazy that's not dagobah
so jacob is not like at least outside
you know no it's just like stage eight
elstree which is a grubby little
security i say no it's a beautiful
historic yeah oh my god how wild i know
i've had moments like that i had a
moment with uh frank oz where i was
doing an audition
for him that that um
it's a it's a long setup for a story
that doesn't require a setup but
basically i did something that made him
laugh he was recounting what i had done
in the scene and he said well i like
what you do you know you came in and you
did that thing
and he just did this little chuckle and
i was like [ __ ] that's yoda
and it was so
to hear yoda laugh out of that and not
be prepared for yoda was
wild wild
because i was probably similar to you i
was
playing the same kind of you know
fascinated by that world um and and it's
nice to still be it's nice to still be
triggered by that stuff you know like oh
yeah
i would hate not to to find myself in a
situation and and find that just like
yeah i know i want to always be that i
know to be just um i know what would the
word be when uh
something is hardened well not not in a
good way uh not crystallized well are
you going with it yes uh er erect um
too messend
um
to be
be too messent by your heroes um
speaking of speaking of having boners
around people you admire what was uh
well
can you tell me about your initial
spielberg encounter because i i know how
much he means to you as a filmmaker um
and of course now you've worked with him
so many times you your relationship to
him must be quite casual at this point
but
what was the initial one like and and
how long did you wait before you nerded
out on him
it was it was nerve-racking i i'll
preface this story with when i was 10
my my
uh he worked in a department store in uh
in gloucester and i i went to see him
and he said
you've got two choices what we can do
tonight we can either go to the fun fair
which was in town it was summer
or we can go and see this film raiders
of the lost ark and i kind of thought
about it and i remember weighing up huh
you know the relative merits of quick
yeah bright lights and rides yeah fun
it's funny
yeah which i'd seen advertisers from the
makers of jaws and star wars i remember
the trailer being on tv yeah and i
thought what this what does he want to
do and i thought i'll let's go to the
movie
so
just cut forward to 30 years later
whatever it was i was in santa monica
and and tintin had come on you know it
was on the cards and i'd heard that
steve and spielberg had wanted nick and
i to play the thompson twins oh wow and
i was in la and and he
he said i'll come down to i got word
come down to giant studios in santa
monica and meet steven
so i drove down there in my higher car
you know like just
white knuckling it down the freeway like
oh my god
and uh
and i turned up and i walked in i was
led in and he was in there and he looked
like steven spielberg he had a hat on he
had a raiders
no smoking his i said this is the lost
ark not oh no not the l.a another now
vegas raiders sports team
and he had he had the the motion capture
camera which is what he was learning how
to use because tintin was a moment
right
wow
and um
and and it was just like being
introduced to
i don't know [ __ ] god i just
know that that you created these things
these i mean the list is like i mean
sometimes i think about spielberg and
like
just the list goes on and it's one after
another it's insane and he's holding the
camera he's like fidge playing with it
yeah because he kind of look because
what you're looking at is a oh yeah
it's like a monitor and it has the whole
3d environment that you're in
on the monitor and you can look at like
a vr thing you can look around at this
and you can choose how to shoot it you
know and of course he's a very fluid
filmmaker he likes to move the camera
and so he was kind of playing with that
and i walked up to him and said hi oh
hey simon nice to meet you and we
chatted he was incredibly personable and
lovely
did he talk about the movies you did he
referenced like i liked you in this or
does he bring up yeah yeah he was like
you know he sean of the dead he really
liked sean and the dead and oh my god i
remember when when he called me for
ready player one it was because
well i gotta i got a message to say he's
gonna call you so i was you know the
time and it was because he'd seen um
mission impossible rogue nation and i
think he said i love the scene when you
had the bomb strapped on you it was
really really good anyway
oh my god oh my god simon i might be
conflating stories but did you say that
you had been you had been working so
much you went away i think i heard you
say this on some podcast you went away
with your family and you said don't to
your agents don't call me spielberg of
course yeah yeah it was the other one
it was after star trek i was like look i
don't want to do anything for a while
i'm burnt out yeah i'm gonna go away six
months off don't call me unless and then
of course he called which is hilarious
that's funny
but the day that i met him in santa
monica that first day it was lovely
and i sort of we did the meeting and i
went outside and i sat on the hood of my
car just kind of getting my breath back
and i called my stepdad
and said so i just
you know it was such a nice sort of
circularity that night of being
yeah that's really cool i i um
i very i so briefly met him that it's
not even worth bringing up which i just
did but i but galaxy quest which which
you mentioned he
uh
i i what i heard was that it was
his decision to leave my character in
the movie so
i think they were going to cut it and
and so just knowing that i remember
thinking at the time
that means that spielberg
saw me saw my face like saw me act saw
me do something that like i enjoyed
doing and i'm hoping people like how i
do it and spielberg saw it and was like
liked it enough to just
not want to excise it from the movie
which was um i think about that
yeah yeah keep it in like oh god it's it
stays in the picture yeah that kid stays
in the picture i also weirdly think
about kim jong-un uh being a big movie
fan and i and i sometimes wonder if he
knows who
do you ever think about whether or not
he knows who you are
i know i do have that thought sometimes
but i wonder who
has watched
you know like our movies i wonder if
like i think his dad was a big dark
i think kim jong-il was a huge had like
a big collection i'm but i'm i'm sure
and then you think well what did he does
he like me does does this despotic does
this like you know
hey listen you know reunification think
about it anyway
this
[Music]
here's something i didn't know that 98
of oral bacteria are good for you
they're actually essential for your oral
health they might not necessarily be
good for your partner when you turn to
breathe on them in the morning but turns
out the fact that all bacteria are bad
it's just a myth and that's why i use
lumino lumino makes toothpaste mouthwash
and whitening products that actually
help your oral health instead of hurting
it they use purposeful and
uncompromising ingredients like sea salt
aloe and coconut oils to clean and
brighten your smile plus everything they
make is certified non-toxic you won't
find harsh chemicals or bleaches and
everything is dentist formulated backed
by over 50 studies and proven to protect
the good bacteria also known as the
microbiome the lumino whitening strips
are so effective
and perfect for sensitive teeth like
mine it only takes about 30 minutes to
apply and you'll see results in seven
days i've tried those things in the past
i'm an actor i'm vain i need to have a
nice white smile i'll admit it and a lot
of those whitening products they make my
teeth hurt and it brightens your smile
with none of that sensitivity so find
luminous on amazon.com and get seven
dollars off today that's
l-u-m-i-n-e-u-x remember it's spelled
with an x
so you can
x out the harm lumino dedicated to
illuminating better ideas in oral care
we talk a lot about health on the show
i'm trying to stay healthy i want to i
know life is short but i want to extend
it for as long as i can and of course
health is more about diet and exercise
though those two things are very
important it's also about
gut health and i've been taking
probiotics uh they've helped immensely
they've helped some of my less savory
habits i don't fart as much okay
but if you have type 2 diabetes you are
going to need a little bit more specific
probiotic that's why pendulum
therapeutics is so important it's the
first and only biotech company to
one isolate an important beneficial
bacterial strain and two put that strain
into a convenient new probiotic rich
capsule that is formulated to help
manage type 2 diabetes and nurture your
body's microbiome pendulum glucose
control is the first and only medical
probiotic clinically shown to help
manage type 2 diabetes when taken with
medication over time people with type 2
diabetes lose the gut bacteria that help
them digest fiber and manage blood
glucose levels for those with type 2
diabetes diet and exercise alone are
often not enough to manage it so the
best approach emphasizes diet and
exercise and
like we said a healthy gut microbiome if
you or someone you love has type 2
diabetes take control of glucose levels
with pendulum glucose control use code
long at pendulum life dot com to get 20
off your first month of membership
that's p-e-n-d-u-l-u-m-l-i-f-e
dot com promo code long for 20 off your
first month of membership
hello hello again
[Music]
were you working at the restaurant when
you met nick he told uh i think that's
what he said but you were you guys
worked together he was he was working at
the restaurant
oh and um my girlfriend
had gone and got a job there and come
back one night and said oh there's a guy
there there's a guy at work he's really
funny he wants to be a stand-up comic
and i told him you were one
is that could you give him some advice
and i wrote a little bit of paper for
him and then i met him and
and that you know i remember the night i
met him
um
it was just sort of you know it was just
electric it was kind of like yeah
yeah i mean i
i thought i like this guy he's great and
then we went off we spent like three
weeks together just going to comedy
clubs and hanging out oh that's right he
said you would drive him around like
kindly drive him yeah yeah
we were sort of vibing on each other
like like
yeah
and then
and he was like the funniest guy i'd
ever met like there was something about
him which was so
it was so elemental it was kind of i i
was a stand up comedian and he was
funnier than anyone i knew yeah he's
like a force isn't he he's extraordinary
did you then fall into a natural dynamic
as
as a duo start to take shape did you
were you ever conscientious of like
other
you know laurel and hardy or other kind
of um
twosomes well no because at that time we
were like we were just friends it wasn't
the idea of us actually performing
together wasn't a thing he wanted to do
stand-up
i was trying to get him what the thing
that nick couldn't do and he'd admit
this as well is that he couldn't take
that prodigious talent that he has the
the comedic sort of sensibility he has
he couldn't turn that into a performance
on stage right so he would come up in
front of the mic and then he'd get very
self-conscious and ah it
just there was a slight disconnect there
where
the brilliance of him yes would
transpire on stuff yeah yeah and and it
frustrated me and he had he did like
five gigs five were quite good five he
was like booed off
and um
yeah
but by this time we were already like
you know we'd already fallen in love i
just wanted to sort of hang out with him
and then when we came to do spaced
he had this character that he'd often do
just to make me and my girlfriend
laughter army obsessed guy
and um
and
selfishly i sort of
thought hey if i can put this character
in this show
i can hang out with him more because he
can come to work with me
yes
also it's like surefire i mean like you
you out now are probably thinking as a
writer as a creator how do i harness
this this energy this comedic force how
do i
how do i get it so that other people get
to see it yeah it was like i discovered
the power of the sun in the palm of my
hand
i didn't know what to do and i just felt
like
he he's great there has to be some way
of channeling this energy yeah into
anyway so so we ended up doing space and
then by that time we had a natural kind
of rhythm with each other we knew each
other really well and
and that sort of led on to sean of the
dead and and everything else you know so
you were more classically trained you
were you had gone to theater school you
had um
did you harbor any ambitions to do
more classical things
oh yeah i kind of i i did i went to
college in stratford-on-haven
the royal shakespeare company and i yeah
when i was sort of 16 to 18 i just
wanted to work at the rsc and do
shakespeare
and then at university where i did like
a degree in film theater and tv
then i started to get into comedy
because it was there were cabarets and
stuff and then i got very disillusioned
with the state of kind of british
theater and i thought maybe i'll do
stand-up and i can be my own boss and
and so i sort of drifted into comedy
which i loved but
i i did want to do other things but that
sort of became what i majored in kind of
thing and so yeah nick always jokes that
it was like my fair lady
welcome to hollywood your life is over
and you chew with your mouth closed
um yeah
yeah he is he's just a beast um
uh what so so do you still are there
remnants of that simon of that that
early you know uh classically trained
kid um do you ever want would you ever
want to do shakespeare on stage for
example
yeah i haven't done theater for a very
long time but i certainly
i've made a decision to try and maybe
diversify a little bit and do some more
straight stuff and maybe only maybe save
the the big comedies for edgar now and
you know the next time edgar wright and
me and nick work together and then
otherwise go off and try and flex some
other muscles and i've done a few things
recently that have been
i did a really interesting show i think
it's gonna be great for um for peacock
and um channel four in the uk
over the summer called the undeclared
war which is um about a sort of russian
cyber attack on the uk and it's mark
rylance and myself oh wow
and it's a really tall thriller and wow
you know
there's barely a chuckle in it and i i
really enjoyed that yeah
oh wow is that are those um because i
know you've also been doing a lot of uh
you've been shooting mitch i feel like
you've been shooting mission impossible
for
well over a year
forever i feel like
do you can i just say as well because
obviously
you're you're a very versatile actor but
you know you're you're loved for your
comedy but do you do you get that itch
as well i mean i
i what i was just thinking about jiri
[ __ ] which i absolutely love oh that's
great thanks i mean yeah and it was so
lovely to see you in that you know it's
like oh wow
you were great
yeah spoiler alert i uh thanks simon for
saying that it means a lot coming from
you i i wonder how you feel it's the
same
it feels like the same muscle
you're using it feels like the same i
agree
yeah and there you know there's there's
there's a lot of humor in tragedy
there's a lot of kind of
you know whether it's in a through
coping mechanisms or just the irony of
the situation there's comedy to be mined
from awfulness and drama you know yeah i
think when
that that can be the thing that's
missing from some drama is and i don't
mean comic relief by at all but i just
think the natural ebb and flow of
of what is
amusing and what is depressing you know
the balance of life i i think that's on
such beautiful display in uh
in the world's end it's it's your your
character in particular has
that great dichotomy i mean he does
obviously outrageous things and he's
funny on the one hand what a party or he
is but there's such um
there's real sadness i mean you mind
real tragedy in that character it was um
i i love the movie so i love your
performance and it's so much and i had
heard you say that it it was one of your
most personal it was um
and i wonder if you could talk a little
bit about that experience and and
what about it was important to you and
and what about it did you connect with
well edgar jokes that after um after hot
fuzz where i'd basically been the
straight man for the whole movie you
know
40 minutes i don't think well
you know when it came to the world's end
it says i'm going to be the funniest
yeah yeah i'm going to let loose
can you do nick does such a great
impression do you do i'm sure you do n
agarose
it's just sort of talking about that
but nick really exaggerates it sort of
like sort of like sort of like
that don't hear me
what would edgar say if um
how would he invite you to a party just
to get together that turns out to be
like a big edgar wright party
that's all about him yeah you want to
come to a publicly i don't know
we'd probably hear about it via
instagram okay um
it uh yeah but
when i came to do the world's end i
think i it was 2012 so i
i was i had been sober for two years
and i kind of you know and i'd come out
of a time obviously before that when
things were
a little bit out of control for me and
yeah
it was a great way to to to mine that
oh i bet
that state of being when you're when
you're constantly performing
you're constantly showing
something on the outside and yet
something on the inside is completely
different and you're
you know gary is and i i didn't get as
to where gary got obviously gary is like
a suicidal yeah alcoholic yeah that's
fresh from
from a psychiatric hospital we don't
know that first but yeah
he's still
masking this this massive tragedy that
he is with this incredibly effervescent
boolean
madcap fun guy yeah and and the trick
with that character was to show both
things at once you know uh yes well god
there's something
classical about that there's something
shakespearean about that i think that
kind of yeah academy
as actors it's what we
it's they're the real gifts those roles
when you yeah convey something
without projecting it you know yes yes
and or
in fact
ideally projecting the opposite of that
projecting in this in gary's case
yeah and effervescence and uh um
it's it's it's smart and funny and all
that but um it really is that there's
such tragedy in it i'll never forget
that turn and there's there are hints of
it throughout but but you never give it
away until um that beautiful turn at the
end and it's just it's heartbreaking um
there's a bit and there's a bit when
rosamund says that i i like when she
sort of i think when he follows her into
the toilet
and and she sees it more than the boys
doing she sort of says what happened to
you nothing happened and you can see it
it's like oh [ __ ] she can see me yes you
know yes yes there are people like that
i
i met one recently who see you and and
it can be really uh challenging i mean
it can be really unsettling if um if
you're not ready to be seen i suppose um
yeah who who
was that i imagine your your wife in
your life was the person that
that saw you that you can't hide from
yeah she would it was she was the
hardest one to fall do you know what i
mean
hiding booze around the house nick
nickwood as well
and nick was kind of a bit more tough
love on me and that he kind of like
you know
he'd just look at me like
like he was disappointed yeah that was
worse
yeah yeah mate mate yeah yeah i know
that yeah yeah
yeah and nick enjoys a fun time himself
but uh
when
i imagine when you hear it from somebody
who enjoys
who is as fun as nick and uh capable of
like indulging
it's like totally yeah but now we're
both you know now enough well i'm in my
next 50 this year next 50 in march oh
that's right yeah yeah we're we're both
kind of
clean and sober
on the other side of all that stuff but
yeah i love him so much i'm glad he's
doing
yeah
well i'm like
i'm glad you're both doing great and i
look forward to it now you must be sick
of hearing this but i
what's that is there another one in the
works is there another uh pairing do you
guys have anything else planned together
well yeah i mean people always people
are always trying to get us to do things
together but i want to save that now for
the next time
you know edgar edgar and i
have been talking recently i mean we're
always talking you know he's gonna
that's the thing about nick and edgar is
that they're also my best friends you
know i see them a lot yeah people often
say you're never ever gonna see edgar
wright again yeah i saw him last week
oh so you must be talking about a new
project
yeah no he just brought his dog around
to the hospital
but we have been talking about a few
things and i and i'm trying to persuade
him
to grab a moment uh
in the next couple of weeks to come over
and just sit we've been circling a few
ideas and
um oh man you know it'll it'll happen
but it's that it's the
the syncing up our schedules yeah as we
said you know mission impossible has
been going on for a long time now i
think ovid and various other kind of
setbacks um none of which were our fault
but um
we are doing seven and eight back to
back so that's right right oh my god
so now that we've finally managed to
sort of finish seven i'm now
matriculating into eight
and i would imagine all the stories i've
heard about tom cruise who who is one of
my favorite actors i mean i go back and
watch born in the 4th of july and like
yeah i think should have been oscar for
that he really should have and some of
that stuff is so
big and real at the same time but he is
so
so both in that movie uh uh he's so good
when he plays vulnerable you know when
he is
when he plays a flawed person
i mean he's absolutely magnetic you know
i know when he and he does things in
that are that are quite
distasteful you know he has um
he breaks he commits to this
single mother and like he humanizes it
in a way that is so um
attractive attractive yes i'll say it
yeah
uh yeah really attractive and but so
that movie i was like kind of admiring
that movie and marveling at his
performance and um
any time anyone's worked with him on
this show i i have to ask about him
because i'm sort of fascinated about
how he is as an actor and his work ethic
and
what those sets are like
he is
the
most sort of committed professional i
think i've ever met uh definitely and he
he cares so so deeply about
um
about what he's doing you know i mean i
think he's a producer on these films as
well
but his commitment to them
is just total at all times and
you know
it's it's kind of um it's kind of
inspiring you know because then you
obviously want to do that i mean i tend
to just take the piss all the time
that's that
yeah because he kind of he likes that in
a way i don't know why i bet
he's funny right he he's he's very funny
yeah and he's naughty as well like if if
his coverage is done and we're doing
okay and yeah things aren't nice because
we're gonna
he'll [ __ ] around you know he'll screw
up and i know when he's doing it as well
and because i can feel it when he's in a
funny mood and he's he's like a little
boy and he gets all cheeky yeah and it
it it's a it's impossible
what does he do what's an example of
that what what would be like an outtake
that he causes does he like fart and
stuff does he
no well this is the thing he doesn't
like i've seen blooper reels from all
the missions but he doesn't sort of
allow them to be featured on anything
because he he is so kind of invested in
in preserving yeah
the art as in the thing you know yeah
and
he doesn't i think i think that's why he
does it because i see these blooper
reels and i just see wow if people saw
this they'd realize what a fun man he is
yes but
he
but maybe he knows that would hurt
maybe like you said he knows that would
kind of hurt the thing that the
uh yeah yes that's what it is because i
don't think it's that he there was a
there was a scene we were doing on ghost
protocol
and it was me and jeremy renner and
paula patton we were on this private jet
it was a set
and tom ethan hunt had to come in and
say
i lost the guy i lost the bad guy
we were that close but
he's got a bomb that could it was some
really really serious yeah kurt
hendricks has got a bomb
yeah
yeah
he did it once in this kind of sort of
faintly sort of campy way oh yeah after
that
it was it was one in the morning
and you'd have to he'd have to walk up
to us
eyeballing all three of us
and sort of go i lost it
oh man
no money because you had the voice that
previous voice in your head that kind of
campy voice i lost the bat oh man
hendrix got a big bomb
me and paula and jeremy were stacking up
behind each other crying oh man
bradford the director was on the floor
on the monitor and he was going
a [ __ ] director i mean when that
happens the whole set falls apart well
it kind of shows you it actually speaks
to how committed i imagine you have to
be in those movies because the line
between
farce and
really like taught
you know thriller is yeah so thin i mean
that's what a voice like that will do if
you just if i mean if you commit to that
voice it's like forget it they undermine
it slightly undermining yeah so
overblown you know it's so ridiculous a
lot of the time
and um yeah you know we have we have to
say things that are and i have to say a
lot of jargon yes i have to explain the
plot a lot of the time yeah if we don't
get it by the time this happens then
this will explode and if that explodes
then this will happen and then that will
happen and let's begin act three yes and
don't look at the camera and ask
everyone if they get it uh which is
probably tempting okay you follow did
you follow me
yeah yeah you do do a lot of that that
is hard to do my friend john was on csi
miami and he was often given a lot of
that you know but but you have writers
who i imagine help and and you yourself
were such a good writer that you
probably
what a challenge it must be to to kind
of humanize a lot of that dialogue and
soften it in a way that's fits better in
the mouth
well my one of my main
sort of bug bears as a writer is is
exposition is
bad exposition when exposition is
and anytime anyone starts a scene so let
me get this straight that is just like
so what do you know
yes so what you're saying is and then
and then you deliver the you know
that i i always find avoid that in
anything i do i you know exposition
you tuck it in
in places and you hide it under other
information which feels more important
at the time you have to be stealthy with
it otherwise it could be so laborious
well well stealthy or in edgar's case
like entertaining like edgar makes that
stuff a part of his um
uh style which is so funny he makes it
fun yeah um yeah god god i love those
movies i really look forward to the next
one just the fact that you guys are
meeting
um
about anything is is that that it's in
the atmosphere is exciting um we did it
we did a big hot fuzz podcast for empire
magazine it was their 500
podcast or something
and um and so they do a kind of spoiler
special on movies and and so we did one
on on hot fuzz and nick was supposed to
come but he couldn't come in the end
because he'd been
there was a covered exposure which which
meant that he had to self-isolate yes
from a masseuse
yes was that the one
no no this wasn't the masseuse this is a
different one oh no this was a foul one
oh oh okay twice he's he's i think he
exposes himself on purpose so he doesn't
have to leave the hat
let's just before we carry on let's not
uh in any way suggest nick exposed
himself to us no no that could be a
rough sound bite that's that's a
dangerous sound bite
i think he exposes himself on purpose
no no no everyone it's just about covid
it's not it wasn't
a family member
i've got to get it gets worse it gets
worse who happened to give good massages
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
i've heard you talk about sean of the
dead as being
it must have been a surprise the way it
was received and how international it
became that that it you know was such a
big hit in america what was that like
when you saw it kind of taking off or
did you have a sense while you were
shooting it that this is something that
i think people were they to see it would
latch onto
i didn't you know when we were making it
i can't remember what i was thinking it
was just like oh we're making our film i
think i naively assumed it would get an
international release i didn't know
maybe that maybe i didn't even realize
there was a possibility it wouldn't
and um
no i just thought oh all films come out
everywhere don't they but um
you know it came out in the uk and then
there was a i think like harry knowles
that ain't it cool news that uh did a
song so he really championed it
yeah and then we got a lot of
sort of directors and uh people like
george romero sort of got behind it and
um
and and peter jackson and queen and
cleaner that must have mentioned
well that's the weird thing is that
george
w we heard that george was going to
watch it in a in in florida
we we sent him a copy the the huge irony
was that they sent a universal security
guard with the reels as if he was going
to steal
seriously
that is that's funny he he watched it
and he called us and he was so lovely
about it and kind of because it's not
the thing is
sean isn't isn't a spoof of george
romero movies it's
sean is a zombie movie but it's a spoof
of like romantic comedies you know it's
all the beats the richard curtis kind of
like totally you know lie down on his
luck trying to win the girl back yes
but that's juxtaposed with a completely
you know uh none of the zombies are
funny all the horror in it is is kind of
faithful you know and the zombie stuff
is also just as a horror fan so well
done i mean i remember thinking how
just how original it was and and how
faithful it was that it was clearly made
by people who loved those movies who
loved the romero uh night of the dead
and dawn of the deads um it felt so
faithful
uh yeah we were huge fans of george and
and you know had the pleasure of going
out and doing a little cameo in land of
the dead edgar and i have like flew to
toronto and
got to be made up of zombies and and oh
that's cool
you know it was like a little
make-a-wish foundation event yeah
lovely and he was we were friends with
george up right up until you know he
passed away and yeah
a real sort of honor to to be in his
orbit eventually you know like we went
to there was a big land of the bed like
premiere
and um
and this is a good this is a good story
it's like it's been named rocky but
so we missed one
edgar and i flew to new york and then we
got a cessna to pittsburgh
and we got to um
and we got to pittsburgh and all of the
kind it was like george romero day and
also pittsburgh
yeah yeah and all the surviving cast
members of um of dawn and knight were
there and i played johnny and knight
living dead and
um
scott reiniger and ken foreign and all
the all the
galen ross all the all these um kind of
the people that were in those movies
that i love they were all there wow wow
and um but before the film was aired
um we were with quentin tarantino it was
me and quentin and edgar was sat
together
oh my god and this guy
the guy stood up and said okay
stand up if you've ever been in a george
romero movie and of course like you know
a quarter of the audience stood up
because there were all these people that
had been extras in dawn and that lived
in pittsburgh and edgar and i stood up
and quentin was like sit your butt down
you've not been in the george romero
movie that was a you made a movie that
was like a ripoff
i'm like clinton we're in the dead
we are zombies in land of the dead man
so shut up
what is how does quentin tarantino take
back something that incredulous
how does he walk back with complete
humility
by the way that is a really good
question
[Music]
yeah and he's kind of like looks away
from you
there's no eye contact
the great thing was the next day
uh greg nicotero who is a long oh yeah
you may have worked with greg on the guy
on creep show we did a creature episode
which weirdly
oh greg was like a kid in a candy he was
like in the sandbox he
that the end of this episode features
neither i wake up basically and i create
this vr thing and i wake up in night of
the living dead the wrong
movie
and and they all kind of descend on me
it's so cool but but he recreated that
final um you know when he's banging on
the door uh yeah he recreated that
little corner of a room and um uh it was
such a thrill for both of us i'm such a
geek about that movie as obviously yeah
greg
i love greg nicotero well he he's also a
pittsburgh native because he
he his first i think he was on the set
of the original dorm when he was like a
kid yeah before he he ended up in david
obviously but
uh greg took us took us to uh evans city
cemetery where the opening of night
happens where johnny and barbara
are visiting there you know and you see
the first yeah
yeah and then he took us to the
monroeville mall where they shot the
dead
and we we walked around we went up on
the roof you know where they were yes
all different like jc penney's still
there all the shops are there but it's a
bit more modern but behind the scenes in
the kind of in the guts of the place
it's exactly the same that noise that
whine of the generator wow same noise
that you hear in the movie
cool isn't that great when you see those
locations i god i remember being in um
i remember being in a church basement on
the one on hollywood on cuanga cuango as
you're coming from the 101 into
hollywood there's that big with the aids
ribbon on it
right right there and and i was there
with this an ex-girlfriend and i said
god i'm getting this wild deja vu like
really strong like this seems so
familiar she said well you know they
occasionally shoot movies here
and i said what movie have they shot she
said
sister act two
and um i wasn't that familiar with
sister and i was like
i don't really i don't think i've seen
that enough god is this weird and some
time went by and um
i i couldn't stop talking about it and
finally like as an afterthought she was
like
well they i said have they shot anything
else here she said oh well i think they
shot back the future here too and i said
in enchantment of the sea dance yes of
course that's where they shot the dance
and we had been together
and the fact that she didn't know that
that was um
easily my favorite movie that she she
led with yeah yeah that was not a
there's a red flag
i love that stuff and simon i love that
you love it i love i mean it shows in
your
work yeah like you said earlier i mean
that there's still this
sense of joy and i'm a fan you know
that's the thing is
i've got you know we we get to work in
the in the sort of field that we love
and would would probably observe from
afar if we didn't oh totally oh my god
yeah i have a lightning round if you
don't mind if yes
okay
simon what is your favorite emoji if you
use emojis what you what's a go-to
standard emoji for simon pegg usually oh
simon's doing the like tongue tongue out
winky face sorry yes
how else do you say yes audio
and it's the
winky winky tongue out
just kidding
yes it's great right to like set the
tone
yeah well i find i mean it's very
interesting i find i have to use that a
lot with my american friends because
americans don't use irony socially as
much as we do we tend to
we wrap every [ __ ] thing up
everything we say is basically
faintly snide yeah and
there's an honesty people sometimes say
oh americans don't get irony absolutely
not true the best american comedy is is
the sharpest irony you can get but
in a social situation
it's just less used and that's why
people always say just kidding uh even
friends
my friend a friend from of mine
from los angeles will say simon i'm
going to murder you and chop you into
little people and throw you into the
canal just kidding like you don't need
to say just kidding it's fine i get it
it scares me that you do feel the need
to say that
my friend jeffrey
just kidding uh he's he's such a piece
of [ __ ] i'm just kidding
um
[Laughter]
what what were some american comedies
that inspired you some um obviously like
british ones are legendary but what did
you watch american shows growing up yeah
well um i guess we'd get
like you guys would get like benny hill
and faulty towers you get the strange
kind of you know
it wasn't until the internet happened
really that
we started to key into some of that
really cool underground stuff i guess
like the larry sanders show and yeah uh
chandling before that mash
you know there was some really
i mean you know leading on to
oh god i mean it's just too numerous
there's so much good comedy around yeah
but um
yeah
taxi
taxi yeah was um and and monty python i
imagine was a huge
yeah that was a big deal
[Music]
absolutely yeah yeah i bet um have you
met those guys have you met any of the
pythons yeah i did a movie that terry
jones directed and uh wow
it was a kind of uh it was a stranger it
was absolutely anything and i played
this guy who kind of gets sort of
godlike powers but all the pythons were
in it as ali it was actually robin
williams last we played the voice of my
dog oh wow
it's a strange movie it's got an
auspicious cast but it didn't really
it was a bit old-fashioned i think
anyway it was a it was
such a pleasure to work for terry he was
such a sweet guy yeah and uh
michael and john and then i got to go on
i got here's a thing of being like you
know um of the circle of wish
fulfillment was
as a python fan as a kid
python did like a farewell
um stage show at the o2 arena in
and um
every night they do the blackmail sketch
which is a funny sketch from from the
from the tv series and they'd have a
special guest and i got to be the guest
one night so i was on stage with eric
idle and michael palin
doing this python sketch and it was like
that's it yeah oh man oh man uh terry
jones also has my favorite head sad my
favorite voice of the he had he had kind
of uh there was a there was a
can you hear his voice
only the finest frogs
[Laughter]
that's good yeah
and nude the way it says
well it got better a nude um
who was your um who was your first
speaking of carol cleveland and monty
python who was your first celebrity
crush
oh carrie fisher 100 oh my god me too
sorry too yeah yeah i guess that's an
easy one um i've told this story before
but i i um i
when i did the force awakens i i sort of
hung out with her a bit on on the set
and we walked around arm and arm and uh
oh my god
i was chatting with her and i we stopped
and she looked at me and i looked at her
and i the weird thing was i was looking
into her eyes and
i could see that they were the same eyes
that i used to whose picture i used to
kiss when i was seven every night oh my
gosh and i and i said to her you know i
love you
and she grabbed my hand and she got she
looked at my weathering and she went
[ __ ] you
that's amazing
that's because as a kid you don't expect
that you one day grow up and learn that
she's she was like a really funny salty
like
amazing
what is your what is your favorite ice
cream flavor simon
mint choc chip
yes okay
all right yes um
this is agreed somebody said that
recently they said this is controversial
and i said well why would that be
controversial she said well
it's it a lot of people thinks it you
know it reminds them of brushing teeth
or you know something
[Music]
yeah i love it
of the cornetto ice creams that we based
you know that we feature in those movies
with edgar that the the mint chocolate
cornetto is my favorite so that would be
that would be why oh really oh they were
actual
you would actually eat them
oh yeah yeah yeah i suppose yeah yeah um
what is your favorite holiday
christmas
uh-huh yeah it's hard to be i imagine
where you live it's just beautiful it's
very it's very christmassy yeah and i'm
kind of
you know i'm i'm quite an angry atheist
and i don't sort of have any sort of you
know religious investment in it but i
love it and i sing hymns
and i
i i love it i just love it because it's
such an atmospheric it's so tied into
childhood sort of uh you know wonder you
know i know a child's christmas in wales
i guess you were near wales we used to
read that all the time um yeah and i
have a daughter who's old enough to you
know she's 12 now as you know she's a
fan of yours
to make a video for her wow
and she says hello by the way because i
don't know
i'm going to speak to justin jules say
hello oh sweet
but having a kid that you then get to
re-experience christmas all over again
because yes it's a vicarious thing you
know
yes what was there did you have the same
touchstones uh the specials that we had
i wonder that the um snoopy and the
charlie brown christmas and the only
brand we had yeah mm-hmm yeah yeah we
had a few of those and but then and on
our own as well our own weird parochial
christmas events you know
yeah um you know the one i i used to
love and i haven't seen it a long time
is emmett otter's jug band christmas it
was
it was a jim henson oh it was great it
was jim henson characters
uh okay
um
uh what is an acclaimed movie that you
have not seen an acclaimed movie that
you you often get shamed for people
people can't believe you haven't seen it
oh that's a good question i you know
what funny enough i'd literally just put
one of those right and watched uh
gentlemen prefer blondes oh the other
day which i hadn't seen which i was i
found incredibly entertaining
probably one of the old movies like
maybe like
maybe north by northwest oh
great one
what is a game show pastor president
that you'd like to be a contestant on
let me think of one that will because
there's so many weird ones here in the
uk
yeah i quite like the one um
wheel of fortune is that the one where
you have to guess the words
yes that's one of our favorites my
grandma that was her favorite um but you
didn't grow up with that that wasn't
there no but i i i always would see it
on things on american tv and like i want
to do that will you yes the phrase
yes yeah um do you drink coffee or tea
and if so how do you take it i drink
coffee in the morning and tea in the
afternoon so i'll i'll drink
like an espresso in the morning a few of
them
and then later in the day i'll have a
cup of tea
with milk
uh coffee black but tea with milk yeah
no sugar uh if you can learn another
language what would it be right now it
would be korean
because um
tilly is crazy about korean culture
she's a huge bts fan
and stray kids these these incredible
k-pop bands oh yeah
and she loves k-dramas netflix is full
of these amazing korean dramas we're
just watching them back to back one
after the other and also like i showed
her like trained to busan and the host
and old boy
all those great sort of parasite all
those great korea korea has an
incredibly rich culture and i love going
there when i get a chance
i i had a meeting the other day with a
korean film director because
they just don't have any good western
actors over there whenever you see
like
like squid game which is a great show
when the western characters turned up
they were the worst actors in the world
you need some good white people
yeah i
you don't have to hear that you need
good
i know this is the only place where
white people are wanted now i'm going to
go there
i'm going to learn the language and i'm
going to be accepted
i will assimilate respectfully i know i
know i have a bad history
um
i know i've said that before
yeah yeah well that would be so
selfishly you kind of just want to be
just to be in the you know just to be
there just to be working there and and
bring tyler yeah and i do love i love
watching the the thing i love about the
clay dramas is that they don't follow
the sim similar tropes to western dramas
and that's that makes them very
surprising i mean they are you know
there's they're rom-coms and there's
horror and there's
i watched a there's a great one called
all of us are dead which is a zombie the
korean zombie sub genre is really
it's its own thing you know they're
trained to busan it's these really
snarling kind of
yeah i never liked fast zombies i was
always a slow zombie fan but the
train to busan sort of like i was like
okay i get it and i like these guys
um and that was really good but they
they're just very
different to to what we're used to and
so watching them is quite a surprising
and
um
rewarding process and i i i'm loving it
i i would imagine for somebody who's
seen as many movies as you that is uh
that's a rare thing to to be surprised
by a movie to be like surprised by the
indication yeah
wow um okay i'm gonna check it out i
have not seen all of us are dead and now
i really based on that
what a great recommendation um
yeah if you had to choose a different
first name uh simon's a great name but
if you had if somebody were like yes you
can't have b simon pegg anymore what
would you what first name would you
choose
i think i would be
sebastian
oh great yeah there's a classic
dignified sebastian yeah sebastian
yes i like it but it'd be tough if
people don't want to say the full name
because i have a hard time with multi
syllabus
um
if you
sepeg sepeg if you had a sandwich named
after you
the seb peg um
if it's it's the salmon peg sandwich
what is on it what's on your sandwich
the seb sub uh
the sandwich it would be
the segway
we could go on forever yeah
i think it would be quite it would be
quite basic and nick would probably want
to steal this but i would like a ham
cheese
maybe a little bit of hot sauce in there
just to kind of give it a uh
frequency yeah
um
yes something but i said yes like i knew
like i was an authority i don't know
can't
yeah like a kind of a bit of spice to it
yeah not mustard maybe something just to
just to to flip it from the
the classic ham and cheese
but on a nice thick white loaf thickly
buttered
okay no i think nick would let you
take that don't you think he'd want more
like
gravy like mutton or some kind of like
richer meat like
some kind of medieval meat
elk
um
yeah bear
uh what is what is your oh you've you've
uh you have worked with tom have you
worked i was gonna say what is your
favorite tom hanks movie
but i have a word with mom i've done i
did a couple of chat shows with him and
um found him to be a delight yeah i bet
yeah big surprise yeah big surprise tom
hanks is delightful i know i wish he'd
been an arsenal it would have been it's
more surprising
uh probably maybe castaway that's one of
those films that i always
yeah
can't help
watching if i stick it on i have to
watch it all
i know and it speaks to his like
brilliance as a movie star too that he's
able to hold i mean god to hold the
attention to be riveted by one person
yeah yeah um that's a great one um
do you have a favorite cereal simon
granola
ah yeah okay
um i did a movie when i had to lose a
ton of weight and i i literally got down
to about i don't know what it is in
parents but i was very i had no body fat
enough for what what movie
it was for it was it was for a film no
one saw ironically uh
inheritance um which was me and lily
collins it was a kind of thriller and um
i had immense fun doing it it was great
yeah but i was playing a guy who was a
sort of prisoner and i was all emaciated
but when i got there and i knew that
nothing i
it was only like a 19-day shoot so
nothing i ate would appear on my body
for
i bought i went to whole foods and i
bought a bag of granola and a pint of
cream
and i just
had cereal with [ __ ] cream that is so
weird we were just talking about this i
brought up so i do the show with my
brother and
i i had mentioned how i used to love as
like a naughty i use he was making fun
of me for using the word naughty it was
zoe deschanel i was telling her that i
had we were talking about cheerios and i
said as a naughty treat i used to do a
layer of granola then cheerios then
heavy cream on top
and it was
the best and um
he he said you made it sound like you do
that often i i guess i haven't done it
in years i now want to try it again but
i remember loving that that was such a
treat
it's that incredible
sort of
um coming together of sweet and fat yes
yes yes
unbelievable it's so satisfying uh
that's so funny you said that are you
would you rather take a time machine to
the past or the future
that's a very good one uh maybe the
future although i'd be worried that i
would materialize on some kind of
charred promontory in space
oh no you're snow well i guess that's
true it could be in space but i was
going to say you're safe i mean it's
it's uh you get to spend a a length of
time there where you're
you're saying i would l i would like to
see the future just just to see the
thing is you could go to the future and
you could see the world in kind of utter
uh climate chaos come back and tell
everybody that nothing would change yes
that's true don't look up it's true um
uh are you more of a sadly are you more
of a talker or a texter
texter
yeah
um
a night or morning person
morning
uh beecher mountains do you prefer
mountains
uh do you have a favorite
mountainous area
the port de soleil in uh the sort of
french swiss kind of uh ski
area i'm a very keen snowboarder i mean
it's like my happiness you know it's
kind of oh cool
because it's very meditative the setting
the just the alpine set thing is just oh
it's glorious
okay um uh did you have any preference
to toilet roll over or under
behind under under okay uh and if you
would that's our last uh
question or it's more of a request if
you would finish this sentence life is
short so
live it quickly
yeah yes well
uh but i i this was such a fun way to
live it uh it was talking to you i've
been wanting to do this for so long i'm
glad we got to yeah man it's great to
catch up thank you simon thank you guys
[Music]
so that just happened oh that just
happened it's very uh what a pleasant
voice he has to listen to
it's a bit more it's um it's quite
peckish isn't it i realized that i often
think of he and nick frost as like a
modern-day laurel and harvey yeah i
never realized how
reversed it is no i know i know
because exactly
the hardy character was the more refined
yes
yeah and laurel was more of the
buffoonish character yes the more sage
uh i mean he was the more he was the
authority the one with um he was the
straight man
more of the straight man and
yeah that's definitely the case simon is
very staid is that compared to caid yeah
yeah whereas nick yeah you're right
totally right nick is more of the
innocent i guess
just brilliant i mean simon can kind of
i think he can do it all you got really
excited when he said he liked uh
carrie fisher too that was his first
crush yeah well i mean it makes sense
she was
you know i this is going to sound i
don't know who knows but like roll the
dice uh here we go i was five years old
it was my you know it was before i had
seen
attractive women in like at skimpy
outfits i'm sorry i'll say it and like
now she was wearing a skimp out she was
wearing returning the cheddar yes and
she was i think that's objectively true
can you i think you can say
it's that offensive down
it is cutesy is that condescending it
wasn't her choice it was a character
it was and she wasn't wearing skimpy
outfits for the entire series in fact as
far as i can remember that was the only
skimpy outfit yes yeah it was when i
liked her the most i remember
imprinting on me i think the weird part
about it is that the five-year-old
version of you
had any i know you have this thing
sexual feelings about an adult i don't
know if it was sexual at the time it was
just i remember being drawn to it for
some reason like i wanted to
be around i wanted to see it i wanted to
touch probably but i it wasn't like oh i
want to do right right
you hadn't thought it through no no
there was no
it wasn't a means to an end i didn't
know what the end was it was just like
i'm like intrigued by that
well you see that with babies and
looking at
you know
adults
oh i see that quickly you know when i've
been around i see it sometimes actually
with kids with like young like toddlers
and like attractive
women or women who have like
a certain
attraction about them like like open
faces or big eyes or whatever it is
you're drawn strong
magnetic yes you can see it and it's
like
but you know what maybe this is why i'm
being so defensive about it because it
always kind of bothers me when the
parents are like oh he has a crush on
you or like that's kind of gross because
because when you say that then it turns
into something different i know and it
like it completely like uh takes away
their innocence before
yeah i don't like that either it like
imbues it with this like totally
unnecessary like
ugh like
sexual thing that like obviously isn't
there yeah doesn't have a crush on you
yeah i i i really like she has a
boyfriend yes i know it's she doesn't
she's poor she's like [ __ ] her pants
and like she like is it drawn to
somebody most four-year-olds aren't
shooting their pants i don't think
oh really oh yeah well yeah you did i
did
i was like six
um
uh but we digress yes um simon pegg
really cool makes sense that he and nick
frost
clicked right away that it was like
doesn't he describe it as an electric
chemistry like i i said i was around
them very briefly but it was it was fun
to just watch them
socialize and talk about simon kind of
gives them they get they give each other
[ __ ] they're really
funny together i mean as you can imagine
yeah i mean but those types of
friendships and partnerships
it's like you know that when that
happens in life and not that i've ever
had something similar to nick frost and
simon pegg happen to be but well like i
was
like
yeah but we never we didn't meet each
other
but remember when i remember just being
excited to get a star wars speaking of
nerding out when you were born i just
got like
that was boba fett right boba fett yeah
i mean say boba fett or boba fett bubba
fett boba f
is boba fett it is boba fett i just said
boba fett for some reason i i think i
did oh really yeah i think you repeated
how do you say boba tea
boba tea boba tea not boba tea boba tea
my point is mr fett when you
[Laughter]
when you meet someone in life that that
doesn't happen very often where you
i mean i think people associate it with
romantic connections yeah yeah more
often where you meet someone you have a
lot of chemistry but when it happens
with a friendship it's it's like kind of
just as powerful totally well that's why
in a platonic way but it's like
it doesn't happen often
where you meet someone yeah and right
away you know
do i like this person and i'm gonna have
a fun night i know i'm gonna be friends
like i want to be friends with this
person very badly yes that has happened
it's such a great feeling it's a great
feeling and it's it's like falling in
love it is it's like i was going to say
friend love who's the last guy you fell
in love with
uh
you know i really fell in love with alex
klein whenever yeah i can see that i
like i really knew i'd be friends with
them yeah you guys are very
you you really click you click yeah
yeah i thought i um paul downs i was
gonna say paul downs um
speedman scott's baby yeah yo you guys
right away i fell in love with cure
right away
i did i did too and togo and duffy i
mean like the it's funny you know when
you know you know you know you know and
there's still friends i have yeah
exactly like i saw speedman in la the
other day it was really funny that did i
tell you we were both wearing bookmason
jackets you sent me a picture of it
exactly yeah and i was like [ __ ] you
well they'll give you a hint
it wasn't me is he still gory he's still
gorgeous gorgeous he's gonna age like
he's gonna age like paul newman
yeah like a [ __ ] wine oh i love the
uh the american kitty fairy are you
ready for your life to begin yeah did
you did you i saw the actual episode
yeah it's amazing are you the one that
told me about that uh maybe
yeah are you ready for your life to be
and then i'll reach it your life as you
know it is about to change forever
that's my line already the life that you
had previously known before this will
forever be in a distant memory your
friends your family everyone you know in
your district your past life it's a
really non-existent
that's a really good lionel richie
well because he likes to do a luke bryan
i think that your life the the previous
life that you have is going to be in the
rear view mirror you know like much like
the town your family won't talk to you
anymore
they'll be unrecognizable to you after
you become a star
you won't need them for anything katy
perry said it with such
earnestness i know it was like painful
are you ready for your life to begin
like she was like an empress empress i
know of like a
like a planetary society funny you asked
him if he had ever heard of um or if he
had ever seen emmett otter's jug band
and he lad was such a funny reaction he
laughed he's like i've definitely never
heard of that
and i realize you're not
here that's the kind of thing where like
you know some things kind of are ring a
bell or yeah if you haven't heard of it
it's like that's kind of sounds sweet
you could be familiar that if you
haven't heard of it is a crazy name it
sounds like you know you've never heard
of it no that's true emmett otter's
judgment
that happens to me occasionally where
somebody will reference something and
like uh i
like i know i know i have yeah you're
right like most things it's like oh
that's in there somewhere emmett otter's
jug band christmas i can honestly say
that it's a crazy name crazy but fun
show if you if you know you know
i've
never seen it oh really yeah i've heard
of it though oh and we're going to talk
about it oh i'm younger than you i think
i missed that
i think he was big in the early 80s well
see i always liked the idea of um that
you could play i just made that up i
don't know if it was big enough
that's when i remember watching it i i
guess i haven't seen it in a while may
is it
problematic to have a jug band
um are otters problematic
well are humanizing otters well they do
that in the gay community but it's not
uh yeah gay people do it well but can't
straight people
oh that's true i guess i couldn't refer
to somebody as a twink or a bear
i you can't is that offensive i don't
know
because it's not i don't see them as an
otter because they're not an object of
sexual desire uh i don't think that
shouldn't matter
no but but i think there's something
there shouldn't either i think in this
day and age
referring to someone as a bear or a
twink
could be problematic only because you
don't know for sure
that that's how they identify oh you
know what i mean you're right i get what
you're saying i mean if you could
identify you could be
larger and hairy and identify as a
thinner
right you'd have to be careful is what
i'm saying unless you were friends with
someone and you felt a little more
comfortable saying let's look like
yeah and then they would probably
understand why you would mistake them
for a twink or a bear do you think simon
pegg's listening
i think he might be
that's cool but now but now i'm
second guessing what we're talking about
and like i i don't know simon pegg but i
would imagine
he would be he would find it funny that
the majority of us talking about would
be a twink uh former twink yeah yeah i
mean we're all too old to be tweeted
yeah i know i know i know i know yeah
and nick is his partner it would be a
bear yeah um i wonder if people like
because we
we i wonder if they they must have get
that because we often feel that way even
though we look very much alike uh i
often feel there are moments where we're
bickering about something or we're
laughing about something whatever it is
we're like really connecting in public
or i like i i question why you're not
getting the belgian waffle instead of
pancakes or like you know something
where i think oh i bet that
waiter or waitress or whoever thinks
we're gay yeah of course i'll go a step
farther yeah i would say if you weren't
a well-known person people listening to
this podcast
who didn't know we were brothers well i
think we're gay i bet your fame
has
illuminated our heterosexuality yeah
because only because people know you are
heterosexual because they know they know
who you are yeah people don't know who i
am
except there was someone at the airport
the other day oh that sort of knew who i
was yes oh i'm glad you got around to
this i didn't do that i know i know
someone recognized me yes at the airport
the other day because i had my uh
initials on my backpack my backpack that
i've had since the sixth grade
by l.l bean i'd love that you still
haven't i still i still use that and she
recognized me from the show is that the
first time that happened
yeah and i said to her it's the first
time oh you're like you know this has
never happened to me before what was her
name you should give her a shout out
amanda nice
it was two cute kids whose names i don't
remember and uh nice husband oh yeah and
the hus the husband was did he listen to
the show too no he walked over a little
later and she said i forget his name
we'll say phil
oh phil this is um justin long's brother
christian they do a podcast together
that i listened to
and he
looked confused
it's probably like
he's probably like what are you
listening to when i'm not around that's
what you're listening to this guy and
his brother talking why
is my brother don't worry they're just a
couple of gay brothers
brothers don't be threatened
brothers
um it always feels so nice when people
uh come out i was going to a rojas shout
out
great restaurant in l.a and um
there was uh
two women we were taking their table not
taking it from them they were leaving
stealing it no they were they were on
their way out and as she passed she just
said um love the podcast oh that's cool
i listen to podcast is this
self-indulgent that we're talking about
um for sure i mean i guess then you
could say the whole podcast is
self-indulgent no no
no but should we read a letter okay
i hope simon's listening i want him to
like me i would like him so much i know
but i also don't want to sound desperate
that comes across okay
okay from margie
eckelcamp margie cool subject thank you
and uh yes wir hard to say would you
rather
hello long brothers i'm writing from
missouri just southwest of st louis i
can't remember which episode was my
gateway to finding your podcast but it's
been a real joy to go back and try to
get caught up through the archives
justin may have already questioned how
to pronounce my name you know i was
thinking that but i didn't say it it's i
figured it was margie
um only because they are gie it's why
it's i've never seen it spelled that way
it's mar gee
hard g
margie yeah but then she look how she's
like margie does it phonetically mar g
she she says g-e-e
m-a-r-g it's e that's a hard g right no
hard g would be g g
oh it is g is soft i think are you sure
well she spells it the g version no i
know but i always thought the hard soft
was
i thought hard was g and soft was ghee
oh so she says short for margaret
it's not marjorie oh
marg
margie yeah that's all right margaret's
can be called marge sometimes it can be
but yeah margie
it's not it's short for margaret marg
margie
i think it's margie
i think it's rg
oh i i'm listening to the silence and
[ __ ] thoughts i think it's margie you do
yeah oh that's how she spells it g-e-e
hard soft i think hard g is g oh really
and soft g is ghee
really
i'm good i could be wrong
so
oh huh let me see okay uh yeah guess
sounds harder to me
well christian's google it he's juggling
it
in english there are two different
sounds for the consonants c and g a hard
g sounds almost like because a k as in
the words great good and p oh you're
right great good and pig
that's a hard g you're right okay all
right so short stand corrected but i
margie in your defense says it's mar
g the word she wrote the word so it's uh
soft g but it's a hard g short for
margaret uh any who any who she says
margie says
anywho while pursuing the archives i saw
the louis anderson interview and with
his recent passing i thought it would be
a good time to listen yeah i i did the
same
and wow i'd encourage everyone to listen
to the time he shared with you he seemed
like a beautiful soul and was so
encouraging for all of us to be present
in our lives and celebrate those we love
i could not agree more margie i was um
it's i this happened with me in the
grammar our grammar episode um
it there's something about which
speaking of people in the show somebody
in the gym said i i
like
that is wild to me that
strangers know grandma um
it was strange to listen to and and
really moving i i agree with margie in
the
i was listening on the way to work and
it felt like he was there you know felt
felt like he was still alive
anyway um back to margie i was a bit
teary when you ended the time together
with yeah promising to do a part two
yeah my dad passed away uh my dad passed
away in 2020 and while he's at peace and
we are at peace it's really hard to not
wish for a part two yeah to a lot of our
conversations i bet
oh man that's tough i'm sorry margie um
yeah i bet louie and i you know texted
and and then you start thinking
i should have done i i wish
it but it is it's it's margie's point
it's a good reminder to um
soak up the time to really like take the
most shot of every day yeah this short
time we have um and justin and back to
morgan justin i have to give you credit
as you are getting much better as an
interviewer at letting people answer
questions without
oh boy without prematurely interrupting
so your brain right goes to the negative
first right yep it shouldn't
it's a nice thing to say she says please
take this she even says please take this
as a compliment i'm a professional
journalist
wow okay well so then she definitely
knows the difference between a hard and
soft g yeah so it's definitely margie
yes yes
um okay well
thank you for that i'm going to try to
take that as a comment oh you are
getting better at that yeah but i will
say
anytime you do interrupt someone
it's not because you don't care what
they have to say or because you're rude
it's because
i would guess it's because you care too
much and you're eager to eagerness to um
you know
join in yeah and identify and yeah but
um i i do remember
that is something that i i've been
admiring in interviewers uh lately like
in people that i would dick cabot i was
just gonna say yeah so you don't bother
to think dick kevin's the patient
interviewer the great interviewers are
really good at listening listening i
know yeah
as i cut you off to answer listen
to complete your thoughts
um okay thank you back to margie thank
you for your work and sharing these
interviews i've been a remote worker for
more than eight years and podcasts such
as yours help keep me company during
mundane tasks paperwork organizing she
says i have a would you rather as a
small bit of payback for the
entertainment you have brought to me
would you rather constantly smell onions
that's a good one
constantly smell onions
or have the tips of your fingers tingle
at all times
uh
huh
that's a good one
oh man and then she says thank you so
much are you um
are you imagining cooked onions or raw
onions i'm imagining raw ones i would
rather smell onions i think
what depends on how potent the smell is
and how bad the tingle is exactly they
are i would say the the way i'm
picturing it i would rather smell onions
because yeah tingly fingers seems really
annoying to me at the point where you
wouldn't be able to like yes it'd be a
constant it would be hard to sleep it
would be i would imagine that would be a
fit any physical thing like that would
be tough but i will say and i i love
onions so i like the smell of onions see
i but
um if this smell was so strong that i
like couldn't taste other food right
that's like overwhelming my old factory
experience
then maybe i'd pick the
tingly fingers but it would just be a
constant awareness i think whereas like
with an olfactory change i think you
would get used to that maybe i always i
always ask people to taste and taste and
smell would be affected for the rest two
of your five senses would be effective
it's true and i do love those senses
yeah um anyway uh
any any who any who thinks uh thanks
margie that's it that's it happy
birthday to jerry by the way uh belated
very believable that's true that's just
like months ago best friend of the show
jerry's been posting a lot of like
self-deprecating things on instagram
lately
i like that he likes that's that's the
kind of his move yeah he like takes the
power back yeah um i like that yeah
annie who uh thank you so much margie
thank you to simon pegg yes antamargi
yes and if you guys would like to write
in our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
and um we love hearing from you and
thank you to simon for all his great
work he's it's been it's entertained
both of us so much over the years and
you know what got me thinking we should
have we should try to gag right on yes
um the trifecta yeah again and like you
know so we've been doing impressions of
him or nick and simon have and uh and
other people have i feel like yeah he's
so now you can actually he you can hear
what egg sounds like um he is uh
brilliant obviously so uh be fun to talk
to him and it's been fun to talk
at
one of these one of these episodes we
should figure out how to and how to say
that yeah talk uh in your ear holes ew
to fill fill your ear holes with our
sounds how about this we'll talk to you
next week that sounds great
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you've been listening to life is short
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan b monaco and katie allen senior
producer is michelle miesh
who's at a wedding right now sound
engineer sergio enriquez executive
producer marshall louie
for wondering
bye everyone
[Music]
uh sure that's that's fine for me
too then
y'all messed it with me bad
no oh what why would you do this with
you
how long have you been doing that if you
guys are so excited just sometimes
between two and seven months
we
just like had
[Music]
sure
two zero three